et avec nos gammes à la abina
cofondateur du mouvement des droits
civiques et aymeric salma conseil
régional du rassemblement national en
bretagne bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'être adecco sur rt france et mecs
helmand où vient d'entendre ces
réactions d'opposants au texte sur le
séparatisme qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
pour tout vous dire j'ai été choqué par
les propos que je viens d'entendre dans
votre reportage car le monsieur qui
s'exprimait en fait en utilisant des
termes comme l'islamophobie mais ils
attaquaient la laïcité il a dit dans ses
termes qui leur reprochent à cette loi
de cantonner au cercle privé la religion
mais justement c'est le principe même de
la laïcité
c'est dire qu'en france que l'on soit
catholiques juifs musulmans athées cela
est une conviction personnelle et cela
doit entièrement rester dans la dans le
zone privée dans le l'espace privé et
cette intrusion dans la société publique
seulement comme le réclamait ce monsieur
c'est en fait un combat pas contre la
loi sur le séparatisme à combat contre
la loi de 1905
c'est très grave des propos que j'ai
entendus tout à l'heure me choque
profondément
alors ce texte sur le séparatisme est
très large il vise à la fois accroître
le contrôle des associations la
transparence des cultes et de leur
financement à renforcer le principe de
neutralité dans le service public la
lutte contre la polygamie les certificat
de virginité et les mariages français à
lutter aussi contre la haine en ligne ou
encore à encadrer plus sévèrement
l'instruction à domicile toutes les
régions les religions sont concernés par
ce texte
au plan législatif gamme alabina qu'est
ce qui vous semble s'apparenter à un
ciblage des musulmans comme le dénonce à
des manifestants qu'on a entendu à
l'instant bon déjà pour commencer le
monsieur qui a parlé à tête utiliser les
termes un peu maladroit mais ce qui peut
expliquer simplement en substance c'est
que cette loi ciblant tu le sentiment qu
effectivement ce sont clairement les
musulmans de sensible et l'initiative de
la loi seulement très précisément la
très précisément parce qu'elle fait
suite à des actions terroristes qui ont
lieu sur le territoire français et
qu'effectivement avec la potion un petit
peu lourde en ce moment avec le dossier
international difficile sur la question
musulmane
eh bien on fait des lois un petit peu de
rafistolage pour essayer de resserrer un
petit peu
le contrôle entre guillemets de la
population d'origine immigrée musulmane
pour faire ça cette loi prévoit
l'interdiction de vente d'un lieu de
culte à d'autres états étrangers sans
l'accord de l'état français mais aussi
de fermer des lieux de culte quand ils
sont soupçonnés de séparatistes ministre
de l'intérieur envisage d'ailleurs dont
contrôlé à 89 prétendument séparatiste
dell a promu la promulgation de la loi
quel est votre regard est vrai que salma
moi je pense que les financements
étrangers pour des études doivent être
interdits et pas seulement contrôlée par
l'état
je pense que le lait les financements
pourraient être du ressort des camps est
pas due par des puissances étrangères
qui joue justement un jeu de d'affluence
que ça soit le maroc l'egypte la turquie
pour appuyer leur influence sur les mots
pour pouvoir influencer après le conseil
du culte musulman gamme à labinal vous
vous comprenez que le gouvernement
souhaite à légiférer justement sur le
financement des lieux de culte français
par d'autres états étrangers
monsieur se réclame de la laïcité donc
oui jusqu'au bout de la démarche
lorsque le gouvernement s'intéresse au
financement des lieux de culte alors
qu'il n'a pas le droit de le faire
rappelons que la laïcité c'est
l'interdiction du financement des lieux
de culte
voilà donc on s'intéresse aux chinois
feront des 9,8 et dion et donc de la
propagation du fait religieux par des
états étrangers
donc cette idée est un petit peu
simpliste mais en vérité la question
dispose c'est pas de samba est ce qu'on
doit interdire le financement d'une
hutte
mais quels sont les moyens de
financement de culte digne aujourd'hui
le problème c'est que pétition n'est pas
tranchée donc on parle de l'islam
consulaires et en se disant il y aurait
une influence et prospère sur le côté du
type de missions qu'ils auront été
lui-même d'ailleurs j'ai pas élu et à
partir de là ont consacré de sordides et
une cinquième colonne de d'agents
d'étrangers pour l'évaluation mais c'est
un mythe fabrication vous dites que
c'est un mythe paix dans le reportage
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure la
personne interrogée par l'ats l'humain
d'islam politique et qu'il voulait pas
qu'on stoppe l'islam politique donc non
ce n'est pas un mythe
les influences politiques souvent
étrangères sont bien réels et sont
revendiquées notamment par la personne
qu'on a entendues dans le reportage tout
à l'heure 1 il se trouvait pas de chance
je connais cette personne son expression
était maladroit qu'il n'ya pas l'islam
politique
s'il y avait seulement une structure
politique en france qui comprend que les
musulmans ça se saurait
or les rares tentatives d'élections
locales avec une organisation qui serait
quand même l'islam ont souvent pas été
bien loin c'est 10% dans les quartiers
populaires et rien au reste de la france
donc ya pas l'islam politique et encore
moins d'influencé sur l'évolution
politique de l'islam de l'islamisme
ce qui est sûr si l'on revendique des
frères musulmans de l'uejf et qui font
des pressions sur le pouvoir politique
alors d'abord c'est faux lui riait fait
un instrument que sarkozy a mis en place
en faisant le cfcm
c'est une organisation totalement
informelle qui est pas très structuré et
qui ne représentent que des lieux de
culte et les mosquées il n'y a pas de
pression sur l'état c'est un mythe
ensuite vous dit si vous parlez arménien
a par exemple à la structuration
arménienne elle est évidente mais en
revanche vont parler du ufc une coquille
vide compagnie ccm ça n'est pas une
coquille et lui c'est une coquille vide
et il faut arrêter de faire des mythes
comme ça vous parler de deux sauts de
nom comme ça un petit peu abscons mais
dans les faits il n'y a aucun pouvoir de
ces gens là ni d' influence économique
et politique ni culturelle ni rien du
tout donc c'est bien de décès très la
peur dans lequel les gens ont de l'anc
se voit bien ce qui se passe dans les
banlieues françaises dans les bois par
annie ni vous ni les gens doivent voir
où on va partager pendant qu'on est là
dans le cadre non mais vous ne voyez pas
vous n'êtes pas en banlieue donc on ne
sait pas ce qui s'y passe moi je vous en
parlais givi donc simplement les
banlieues français ici pasqua
paupérisation misère sociale 13
économique évidemment et explosions
ayant dans la creuse par exemple la
misère sociale et la pauvreté n'est pas
présente et bien sûr télé présente c'est
pour ça que je parle de banlieue et de
province monsieur mais il y a le
parisianisme qui parlent de la banlieue
de la province il ya ceux qui la vivent
alors ce texte prévoit aussi une
simplification de la loi de 1905 de
séparation des églises et de l'état dont
l'aide qui est apportée au culte on en
parle à l'instant
un renforcement de cette laïcité les
questions finalement de d'obliger le
plus possible les cultes à s'organiser
selon les dispositions de la loi de 1905
événements selon la loi de 1901 sur les
associations concrètement qu'est ce que
cela signifie pour le monde associatif
que vous connaissez bien gamin de gamme
alabina c'est simple au départ il n'y a
pas ce contrôle de l'état sur le 1905 il
ya un contrôle beaucoup de moustiques
sur la question financière en verre
épais 926 vraiment c'est une association
balançant il n'a pas vraiment des cons
tarot alors la question qui se pose est
là c'est une question qui est légitime
c'est comment on finance les bosquets
commençons lever les fonds et ce qu'il
doit y avoir je pense va y avoir un
contrôle au plan comptable
voyez la question de la comptabilité des
mosquées près de pâques
il ya beaucoup de levée de fonds et on
sait pas vraiment où va l'argent
donc ce sera intéressant effectivement
de s'intéresser au financement hybride
tellement je vous laisse réagir déjà
j'ai dû tirer projet un petit point les
lois les associations loi 1901 doivent
quand même des comptes à l'état rendre
leurs comptes rendus de l'association
leur assemblée générale et rampeau
notamment des comptes si elle souhaite
avoir des subventions
donc il y avait même des choses qui
existent sur le financement pour revenir
à cela aujourd'hui faut bien savoir
il ya aussi des financements via
notamment l'achat des produits haddad
qui souvent on ne ne pouvais pas parce
que beaucoup d'abattoirs pourtant fondu
tout halal notamment réside et où il n'y
a pas de parking par haddad puisque est
un des moyens
lorsqu'on tâche et vous les citoyens qui
ne sont pas en participe au financement
des post et les sites de mon point de
vue n'est pas normal sur cette question
la nina des produits halal 1 tout
d'abord fall of man
encore une fois c'est un mythe quand on
connaît pas le système d'abattage rituel
on ne dit pas que toutes les les
le mode d'abattoirs l'abattage se fait
par par animal ya pas assez de
structures pour cela et vous nous
annoncez que le
des privés financer les mosquées quand
on lance jardel de la formation existe
des abattoirs qui ne pratiquent pas le
pratiquer autre chose que les annales en
région parisienne évidemment qu'elle est
évidemment ah bon vous avez pas de
tactique où vous n'avez pas de
statistiques ou pas dans le vent est à
peu près trois grands le très gros
abattoir qu'il le faut et tout le reste
ça se fait de façon artisanale mais par
contre quand vous dites qu'ils financent
les mosquées vous dites est une
contre-vérité que flagrante tout haut
niveau sa formation elle vienne nulle
part il ya un contrôle g elle sur le
plan fiscal des revenus des sociétés qui
ne peuvent pas faire de dons sans
fondations donc si oui cela il faut
merci à tous les deux messieurs aura
l'occasion de revenir sur ces questions
dans une prochaine édition on suivra
évidemment l'évolution de ce texte de
loi qui arrive donc en séance plénière à
la fin du mois au sénat merci à tous les
deux gammes alabina cofondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques eric
salmon conseiller régional du
rassemblement national en bretagne